in this video we'll be talking about
anti-epileptic drugs and how
anti-epileptic drugs work at a molecular
level in order to understand how these
drugs work we have to first understand
what is epilepsy so epilepsy is a
chronic neurological disorder which is
characterized by recurrent unprovoked
Caesar so these seizur are thought to be
abnormal and excessive electrical
activities of the brain that leads to
Temporary disruption of the normal brain
function but why does these Shure occur
before that let's quickly look at some
of these common symptoms in epilepsy so
it includes Contracting and jerking of
the muscles loss of consciousness then
weakness confuse speech starting anxiety
Etc so the biological basis of the
epilepsy includes the circuit imbalance
let us understand what is that so
basically inside our brain there are
neurons formed forming neuronal circuit
and these neurons in the cortex fires in
a specific pattern this kind of
patterned firing is important for
information encoding now this pattern
firing is possible because there are
inhibitory and excitatory neuron
regulating the exact amount of activity
in this case the red neuron is the
inhibitory one and the blue neurons are
the excitatory ones so these kind of
interplay between inhibitory and
excitatory neuron makur the activity is
not too low or not too high and it is
kept in a steady state Baseline level so
obviously this particular aspect is
abrogated in context of epilepsy so in
epilepsy what happens is there is an
excitatory overdrive also there could be
an underdrive in the inhibitory
responses so either of that can lead to
basically epilepsy so the gabic system
can fail to inhibit too much excitatory
overdrive or there could be more and
more glutamate release in the synapsis
that can lead to the hyper excitatory
changes there could be focal Caesar that
means the electrical imbalances
happening only one portion of the brain
or there could be generalized Caesar
which involves the entire brain most
common is the focal Caesar but the
generalized Caesar is also not
uncommon now there are many category of
drugs that can block these Activity one
category is known as voltage gated
sodium channel blockers and these drugs
are the following the most common ones
and the most popular ones like uh phone
phin
phosphinito then
caram so these are very hard to
pronounce but
car Zine then
lrene so these are difficult to
pronounce but all of these drugs belong
to the voltage gated sodium channel
blocker category but let us understand
how does these work even if they are
difficult to pronounce so all of these
basically inhibit the voltage gated
sodium Channel present in the neurons so
these voltage gated sodium channels are
really important to evoke the action
potential in the depolarization state
there is a huge amount of sodium influx
inside the neuron now if these drugs
inhibit these voltage gated sodium
channel the depolarization can be
inhibited now then there are Cate of
drugs known as calcium channel blockers
or voltage gated calcium channel
blockers like ethos sumide and levit
ritam so basically these category of
drugs again known as calcium channel
blockers block the voltage gated calcium
channel in the pre synaptic terminal
voltage gated calcium channel is really
important for synaptic release and this
synaptic release evokes the post
synaptic activity in the next neuron so
obviously if the calcium channel is
blocked then the activity Can Be Tamed
down and this is how the category of
drugs calcium channel blockers work now
in a glutamergic circuit the glutamergic
neuron is not the only one there are
also gabic interneurons so first of all
in the presynaptic terminal there in the
pr synaptic ter terminal there would be
a action potential that is reaching the
terminal this lead to the
neurotransmitter release and in the post
synapse there would be several glutamate
receptors such as nmd receptors such as
Amper receptors now that lead to a
cationic influx so cation would go in
the post synapse and make the uh
potential more positive so this
potential change might lead to an action
potential in the post synapse in
contrast there could be garic neuronal
terminal also releasing in this
particular synapse so
gabic uh uh neurons release Gaba as a
neurotransmitter that binds to Gaba a
and Gaba B type receptors these are
voltage these are basically liated
chloride channels so once Gaba is
released it would lead to annion influx
in the Pro syapse that would reduce the
membrane potential and basically reduce
the chance of another action potential
so this is how the Gaba and nmda or
glutamate interplay in the synapse
regulate the gain of a synapse or it
controls the synaptic activity another
point is these aspects can be modulated
either there could be a high level of
gabic activity in the synapse that can
tame down activity also there could be
glutamate receptor antagonist that can
prevent the glutamate receptor to open
all the time that would also balance the
hyperactivity in the synapsis now there
are also category of drugs that you can
already understand so basically there
are Gaba Agonist such as velpro acid
benzoin vigabatrin and tiagabine
so basically all of these category of
drugs increase the garic inhibition in
these synapses and thereby decrease the
overall circuit
activity then there are glue R
antagonist these antagonist includes
Topiramate and felbamate so all these
are actually preventing the post
synaptic glutamate receptors so these
post synaptic glutamate receptors
correspond to higher or uncontrolled
activity if if those are blocked then
the activity can be controlled and
checked to a baseline level just to
summarize what we learned but before
that basically let me tell you that all
these anti-epileptic drugs comes with
some sort of like U um drawbacks or some
sort of like uh side effects for example
the most common one which is used is
velpro acid this increases Gaba levels
and also inhibit voltage GED sodium
channels but it has side effects so
vulpro acid can reduce the high
excitability to desired level but it can
be it can be toxic during pregnancy it
could be teratogenic that is why it
cannot be used when it is uh pregnant uh
when a woman is pregnant and undergoing
seizures so basically it is used to
treat generalized Caesars absent Caesar
and bipolar disorder also the category
of drugs like uh sodium channel blockers
like uh phiton phito and
caramine uh
carbamazine so these drugs which are
again hard to pronounce all of that has
certain amount of maybe liver toxicity
some might have different kind of like
toxicity which can be evoked in the
system so that is why with the doctor's
prescription this has to be used in a
proper
way so let's see what we learned so far
there are uh the gabar jic there there
are antiepileptic drugs which can be
categorized into four broad categories
sodium channel blockers
then Gaba Agonist which alleviate or
basically positively regulate the gabar
jic input in the synapses glutamate
receptor antagonist which prevent or
inhibits the glutamate receptors and the
calcium channel blockers each of that
these category of drug has their own way
of working but a combination of that can
be used based on the physiological
situation and underlining disease
condition that is why conducting a
particular clinician is really important
if you are facing SE seizur I hope this
was useful if you like this video give
it a quick thumbs up don't forget to
like share and subscribe see you in next
video